after filing that marriage uh
application that's why i
i put it on a hole i asked him to put it
on hold
this is stupid i'm not doing this
anymore
well at least the chair didn't get
thrown this
time it
[Music]
jenny tells smith she is going back to
america after he confessed to telling
the lawyer to put their marriage
paperwork on hold behind her back are
you embarrassing the
what is wrong with you she went gangsta
on them too
we'll get into submits interesting
response to jenny's reaction and what
she plans to do next he's not giving you
what you deserve right
just walk away
plus
when you marry me
yes victor randomly proposes to ellie
after they had this huge fight about him
using her for money and let's just say
the proposal was real creative and did i
mention random
wait i have a
christmas i want to do something crazy
let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia before
we talk jenny and submit who was
sweating by the way he was so nervous i
want to take a moment to say thank you
for watching the people who show love
with their comments i see you i
appreciate you and the people who come
back these recaps help me grow in so
many ways and i just want to thank you
for playing a part in that cheers cheers
all right at the top of the episode
jenny thinks she's in the process of
getting married but nothing's really
happening as we saw last week following
their trip to the lawyer to file their
marriage paperwork which takes around 30
days to get approved submit called the
lawyer and told him to put the paperwork
on hold keep in mind
that each month jenny has had to worry
about her tourist visa expiring
so every day they wait counts when it
comes to her peace of mind it's a boy
and now i'm an uncle at the beginning of
their conversation submit revealed that
his brother and sister-in-law had their
baby so his family is having a blessing
ceremony for the child so it's just
family only not
not outsiders people who are not family
and of course jenny was not invited they
said not now maybe sometime later they
just accepted us as a couple
things take time cement is talking about
things take time
i'm sure jenny knows that if anyone
knows that it's her she does not need a
lesson in patience okay it's been nine
years
i'm tired
and then she has to hear this your
parents need to hurry up and get over it
because we're going to be able to marry
in about 30 days
actually there's something i need to
tell you after filing that marriage
application that's why i
i put it on a hole i asked him to put it
on hold
without me even knowing you just called
the lawyer and told him to stop him i
mean why would you do that because he
doesn't want to get married
at this point
that's a fact
people change it comes with those
changes and his excuse once again
he fears marriage will change
jenny but let's get real she's 63. how
much changing is she really going to do
and i'm not saying that to limit her
all i'm saying is i'm sure she's in a
place where what you see is what you get
she's already proven the type of woman
she is i'll stand by you
i'll stand by you
obviously to a fault you should support
me by understanding the reason
and
how about supporting me
i've stood by you through everything
i've been by your side through
everything jenny went on to say that
she's going to head back to america yeah
i guess i will be done with that which
caused cement to get offended and
accused her of using going back to
america as a weapon
but all the while he's taking advantage
of her loyalty and the fact that she
won't actually leave
either you want to marry me and be with
me for the rest of your life
or you don't
either
okay so you're going to call the lawyer
and tell them to resume the process
i will
give me i will win i will do it by
myself don't force me and i will do it
you don't want to marry me absolutely
100 you do not want to marry me we're
gonna get married like in as much time
we're gonna take
this is stupid i'm not doing this
anymore we need to start making a list
jenny's epic walk-offs
and use of chairs are you embarrassing
the
what is wrong with you don't you know
how stupid you look sitting there saying
nothing yes jenny bucked on submit and
he continued to say nothing except calm
down oh nothing i'm just asking him to
calm down until she told him to go on to
his family celebration and let her be i
think i have decisions to make i can't
just keep letting him
do this to me gently threatening to
leave it brings up to be like my
rebellious nature that i don't want to
do something when somebody is pushing me
that you have to do this or let's do it
right now that rebellious nature will
have you lonely in india submit it is
not the time this is what uh exactly my
fear about marriage like after getting
married she gonna try to control my body
it's wild how fear is not even allowing
him to see his situation clearly he's
literally thinking worst case scenario
when he can be spending that same energy
thinking about what can actually go
right yeah i know it's not easy to turn
off the voice of fear but it's the
moment by moment choice we all have to
make
krishna
after their fight instead of sitting at
home throwing a pity party i was so
proud of jenny when i saw that she chose
to do something constructive and go to
the temple
it's always a very calming place and i
definitely could use some calm right now
jenny's friend at the temple eventually
joined her and jenny opened up about
what she's going through he thinks if he
marries me it's gonna hurt our
relationship and i'm gonna change
and what do you think
no if anything i'm gonna become a lot
more happier and feel a lot more
comfortable her friend responded by
telling jenny flatout to leave submit
he's not giving you what you deserve
right
just walk away and although jenny
admitted that her advice was really good
i think we sometimes forget what we owe
to ourselves yeah yeah she feels like
she's at a crossroads because even after
everything submit has done
she still feels more love from him than
she has ever felt from anyone else
maybe he does need to be by himself for
a while
maybe then he'll find out what does he
really want
[Music]
i need to be strong and think about
myself first
[Music]
even if it breaks my heart into a
billion pieces
[Music]
to walk away after nine years and
everything she's sacrificed it's tough
especially when submit isn't out here
running the streets but instead talking
about he's scared how are you
okay
all right i'm not gonna go too deep into
ellie and victor but i had to show you
this proposal you don't even give me
that quite awful lots of money either so
really if you want to add it up it's
quite a lot after an intense fight that
started when ellie raised concerns about
how they're going to make money on an
island that's struggling due to covet
and a devastating hurricane since the
only thing you want back is your money
you sent to me so i'm gonna give that
back to you i never even said
the next day they apologized to each
other that's when victor proposed to
ellie with a seashell i want to do
something crazy you see the beauty of
this yeah yes a big one
the ones that they used to tell you when
you were a kid to put up to your ear so
you could hear the ocean
it's for a symbol of love
i had a ring
for you
and the hurricane
it it gets lost like most of everything
is victor
lost in the hurricane
okay i grabbed this shelf
to
ask you
if um
yeah if you would marry me
i thought the ring benny about ari that
cost less than a dollar was different to
say the least but victor has him beat
with this seashell and yes i know
material objects are not everything it's
the love that truly counts that being
said
i personally would prefer for you to ask
me to marry you with nothing instead of
giving me a big seashell to carry around
she can't even put it in our pocket
would you marry me
yes
okay
but hey she said yes she's happy and
that's all that matters
of course i i wanted to say yes you
wouldn't want to marry me last night
though i wouldn't want to marry you last
night
the entire proposal came off a bit
staged for me it was just random it came
out of nowhere they were just fighting
and not knowing what they were going to
do with their lives but that is 90 day
foia i don't know if it's gonna affect
congratulations to the couple
all right next week it looks like cement
finally got it together and he and jenny
are gonna get married tomorrow i'm
marrying submit and i'm feeling so
excited this parent said they're not
going to stop us but we're choosing not
to tell them till after we're married i
don't think it's right she can think
it's not right all she wants but it's
been nine years it's happening
all right 90 day fans fam there won't be
a recap next week due to the holiday but
i'll be back the following week with
everything you need to know in the
meantime make sure you stick with et
because we are covering it all happy
holidays see you next time